hi Leon yeah okay cool
how's everyone doing how amazing is Jase
conf Iceland so far yeah okay stop I
have a talk to make so let me start with
confession I less than three JavaScript
JavaScript is amazing and weird and pure
and awesome and strange javascript is
the only language I know of where you
take your code run it through an igloo
fire on it to then run it through a
predefined and I mean we've created an
ecosystem that allows people to
contribute so much that now we
constantly complain when people
contribute things and javascript is
everywhere so my browser runs JavaScript
my server runs JavaScript my TV runs
JavaScript my washing machine
well that doesn't run JavaScript that
probably runs C++ but only because you
need pointers and memory management when
you're handling soft fabrics and and
according to some TV shows JavaScript
can even run weapons guidance systems
well only if you're using jQuery that is
like if they haven't uploaded the code
to github so I didn't test it yet but it
looks legit so we just is is you know
it's ubiquitous everyone uses it and you
can you know do everything with it but
you don't have to trust me like you
don't have to trust what I'm saying you
can trust this book from 2003 literally
titled how to do everything with
JavaScript and this book teaches you
amazing things like version one point X
or version 2.0 new stuff okay
so javascript does a lot of things but
I'm here to show you maybe things that
you weren't we thought weren't possible
of JavaScript or kind of off the beaten
path
the cool thing about web technologies is
that they allow all of our ideas the
good and interesting ones as well as the
dumb and silly ones okay so my name is
at offer v I come from you from Tel Aviv
Israel where the spoken language is loud
Hebrew and you might not notice but my
name offer in Hebrew means fun you know
like Bambi not sure why I just told you
that does seem important at a time I'm a
designer a musician I'm sometimes a
gamer and it turns out that javascript
is really good for all of these things
so that makes me a developer in my day
to day work at a company called echo as
a creative developer what exactly is a
creative developer according to some
definitions those being my definition
that means someone who works with other
creative people like film maker game
makers musicians designers to do all
sorts of cool interactive things on the
web and I want to start by telling you a
little story about myself and how I got
into web development so the year was
like 97 or 98 and I was 15 years old and
I was spending a weekend over at my
grandfather's and it is there that I
found a book about HTML and that book
was mesmerizing I remember working hours
of notepad and then Netscape for like
trying to to figure out like what this
thing does and I read about this amazing
technology called links I allow you to
connect one web page to the other web
page and that seemed amazing like that
seemed but the problem is it didn't work
so well for me like I didn't know what
was the problem like I I knew I did
something wrong but what was
like water song and then it hit me after
a few hours you see it's not called a
Herff element it's called a RIF element
cuz that makes so much more sense you
know riff and not hurt anyone you
understand why I didn't have a
girlfriend until date is funny what fast
forward a few weeks later and my I had
my first website up on Geo CDs does
anyone remember Geocities yeah I don't
care it looked kind of something like
this
[Music]
actually it looked more like this and
you know you're laughing at this because
it's you know it's hilarious but we
didn't have fancy technology back then
we didn't have CSS and the cloud or any
idea what we were doing we had to build
our websites with nested tables I mean
these kinds of nested tables and long
not long after like I honed my skills I
worked on making websites in the early
or late 90s that is and I finally as a
teenager was able to make some pocket
money by making websites for companies
so like one of the first websites I've
ever made an actual company paid me
actual money for this thing and I don't
know it looks like this like maybe shoe
shaped sidebars were all the rage back
then but uh the funny thing about this
is that it actually has a button that
allows you to turn off JavaScript how
that's an amazing feature but okay
enough about me and my sense of
nostalgia nostalgia let's talk about
JavaScript so what is javascript jscript
allows us to add functionality to
websites so turn them from static things
to interactive experiences so take a
look at this simple phone input number
phone number and put for example so you
know it's style 9 through CSS but this
has a slight issue because like if you
want to use this you need to like point
your mouse at the input and then you
know use the keyboard to input your
numbers and like that's just inefficient
that's inconvenient you'd say like maybe
we can add buttons so that you don't
have to use the keyboard if you don't
want to so okay that's really easily
solve JavaScript let's advance there
problem solves like now the user can
just click on that bounty which is his
or hers phone number and we're done and
I know what you're thinking like this
isn't this is a joke this is an
inefficient method of inputting numbers
so yeah I know I hear you let's fix that
that let's make this more efficient with
JavaScript there we're done and and I
know where it's like where we're already
we're already there
but we can continue improving this I
mean JavaScript gives us so much power
and strength we can make this just
better for all of us all of our users we
can just you know you can endless so I
studied design at the Bezalel Academy of
Art and Design in Jerusalem which is one
of the best design schools in Israel
with one of the worst design logos in
Israel like I don't know what they were
thinking it's like I can't even okay so
when I when I studied there I came to
realize just how amazing would it be if
we can connect technology and art and
what technologies allow us to do that so
check out this example from mental oh
yeah and here we see using canvas and
JavaScript an interactive generative
artwork where every time you click you
get something completely new so every
user that but that just plays with it
gets his or her own artwork how amazing
is that and that's JavaScript I mean
this just you know just code just just
script and this creates these amazing
patterns but you can take this a step
further you can transform this into 3d
for example so this one from the Google
later arts team generates does
generative machines via 3GS and WebGL
and JavaScript so every time you click
generate you get this new machine this
beautiful thing that is generated from
seemingly randomness or another example
would be this example where you have
procedurally generated all tiny
airplanes so every time you click on the
next button you get this new flying
machine and that's that's super cool if
you want
learn more about generating things I
should I definitely recommend you to
take a time machine and go back into
Kate captains talk yesterday and if you
don't have that then when the talks are
up you should check that so these are
all personal experiences so you see them
on your computer on your own personal
monitor but just script can do so much
more it can go out of your personal
monitor and turn into a public thing so
this by this work by marpie a Polish
base polish-born SAN francisco-based a
digital artist lets users play and
generate 3d objects and worlds using the
3GS and the HTC vive so this is an
public and art piece in a public public
space and users can then take the things
that they did and print them in their 3d
printer and you can even go bigger than
that so there is a country somewhere
closer than North Pole or so I've heard
called Iceland and there they have
sometimes they do a conference where you
can actually paint on the building where
the conference at if you ever get a
chance I definitely recommend going to
that conference but but but art is a
really good way to to learn and
understand things it's it's a service a
good way to and the learning tool so
this is a project like a self project I
made while I was studying design and I
was really obsessed with the idea of
evolution so evolution has a really hard
concept to understand and visualize
because you have like mutation and and
survival of the fittest and time and
generations so I thought like maybe I
can create something that will help me
understand it so I did this little coat
pan with just you know canvas and
JavaScript and this has digital
creatures with very simple rules big
creatures eat little creatures little
creatures eat food
those creatures run away from Bigfoot
creatures and then you get this like
from simple rules this amazing system
which it's kind of like a virtual
aquarium that you can look at and all
these emerging patterns arise and it's
just mesmerizing it's just you know
simple JavaScript so I thought okay how
can we take that a step further and I
turned this into 3d you know because 3d
are it's always nicer but the cool thing
about that is the web is all about
sharing so you can share your experience
with someone else so I thought about if
I have my aquarium and you have yours
what would happen if these two
ecosystems would were to meet so if I
have my creatures and I open a portal up
to your browser where you have your
creatures well how would the two
ecosystems interact which well one of
them completely obliterate the others
will new creatures arise like that's
super cool that's something you can do
just by typing javascript and hitting
refresh a lot of the times how amazing
is that but there are different ways to
do learning so one of these is machine
learning and JavaScript also allows you
to do that so Jeff's - it might not be
like the first thing you think of when
you think about like machine learning
but turns out that's the possibility so
deep learning GIS is a machine learning
like library in JavaScript and I'm gonna
show you an example here and the way it
works is that I'm gonna play a little
melody and then via machine learning
we're gonna hear another melody that's
based on what I just played so I just
write this out
I didn't say it's gonna be a good melody
just that it's kind of work okay and if
we're on topic of music music videos so
I remember again as a kid watching being
glued to the screen watching MTV and
which one and those all were passive
experiences but the web allows us to be
interactive so this is kind of an three
dreams of black where you have 2d
animation 3d animation whatever the
other points the mouse like the stream
of animals run around on the building
and that way every user gets his or hers
own personal experience and it doesn't
end there
so this video clip for 4-acre decades
fire reflector uses WebGL and shaders so
wherever you point the mouse like
there's an image manipulation there and
also some 3d where the the dancer in the
video has this 3d thing overlaid on top
of her which you can play super cool
stuff and I mean the options are endless
this video by real estate is an actual
like canvas that you can paint on to you
like here I tried to tame the sky blue
this is really hard when the video keeps
moving but you know it gives you
something to play with for your you're
creating art on top of someone else's AR
and this is something that's only
possible due to web technology the next
project is something I'm really proud of
is something I did at work
this is the official video for Bob
Dylan's like a rolling stone so what
happens here is you have sixteen
different channels of video and in each
different Channel the characters in the
video are lip-syncing to Bob Dylan Dylan
and song and then the user can pick
which channels watch so instead of
watching one music video you're like
kind of creating your own personal music
video and again this is like web video
it's just
you know what could video player in
JavaScript and there are challenges here
but it's just pointing your browser
somewhere and seeing this pull so okay
you can clap it's okay that's one of the
things we do one of the ultimate forms
of interactive entertainment is video
games subjects really close and dear to
my heart and video games come in all
forms and sizes especially on the web so
video games can be something really
small like this mini game and the
website for the magicians a sci-fi TV
show where they use canvas and HTML and
some video to create some engagement
while you're watching while you're
interacting with the website or a video
game can be like a 2d thing this is a
game I made to teach kids concepts in
evolution have I mentioned that I like
okay nevermind this was done with 2d
library called phaser which is based on
a renderer called pixie but you know
again you can let take this to 3d so
this is an actual 3d pinball game
running in the browser and the
interesting thing here is that there's
physics involved there's a library
called p2 physics in the background
actually doing the calculations so you
have physical simulation again running
in the browser but everything that we
just saw is a single-player experience
so it's just you sitting in front of
your computer or mobile or whatever
playing but the web again is all about
connecting people it's all about sharing
so the natural step from this is
multiplayer games players that have many
players this one called Wanderers IO by
game developer and designer called
resinar gives you control over a tribe
and then you fight other tribes for
resources for land and that's super cool
I mean games are usually written things
like C and C++ to be close to the
mell or whatever but then you have to
download drivers and update your
graphics card and you know all these
things but what if you just point out
your browser to webpage and just play
with someone else without having to
download anything so that is what I had
in mind when I wrote this library Lance
would you can find Lance DG and Lance is
a kind of a server and a client that
allows people to create their own video
games online video games web video games
without having to worry about writing
net code or synchronization or all the
ugly stuff that I had to pull my hair
over to do and what can you do with
Lance so this is a game that I made with
Lance
it's called sprocket league and it has
nothing to do with any other game with a
similar name but in this game each
player controls a car and these car
these cars actually play soccer and you
you this runs with 3d physics engine
running on the server on the client and
again this is all web technologies this
is all stuff then you can do with just
notepad you shouldn't do this with
notepad but you can if you want to okay
another really cool technology that
that's up and coming but also out there
is web assembly or its precursor ASM
which essentially asks you to take other
languages like C or C++ or could be
anything and compel them to binary that
the browser can understand and then you
have the browser running something
that's far more effective at computation
so what does this help us with an
example we'll be porting the entire
unreal game engine which is like a
serious thing web a game engine and run
it in the browser using WebGL so what
you're seeing here is not JavaScript it
wasn't written in JavaScript but it runs
in the browser and JavaScript can
interface with this and web assembling
is going to be gratefull a lot of things
that are computationally expensive like
audio manipulations video
filters everything that needs some juice
powering it but I am excited about a lot
of things that have to do
Bertrand and running in browser so what
if and bear with me what if you could
run windows 3.11 in the browser how
amazing would that be so you could just
like open up paint and do something or
you can like open up so later you could
completely completely reimagine how was
it when you were sitting in your mom's
basement in the 90s and this gets us to
their next technology which is what
virtual reality or what we are so maybe
you've heard about this but a way to
learn about subjects that I don't know
is to a way that I like is to look at
stock photos of that specific thing so
if we look at stock photos of web we are
we can learn all sorts of things like
for example what VR is kind of taking a
stroll up in nature and maybe we have
rainbows coming out of your crotch or
maybe what we are is sometimes being
attacked by really old phones or or
maybe you don't need to put anything
like you maybe you not need to put VR
goggles to be in what we are maybe you
just need to take headphones and then
put them on your eyes and pointed
something and that works just as well
but we are and what we are specifically
is all about putting you inside a
virtual world so in this example you're
in this musical landscape we have we
have sound yeah okay and and we have
these
cute tiny creatures where everyone does
has its own little sound and you can
kind of play around with them in this
thing but virtual reality is a
oftentimes product of 3d models and like
something that's completely virtual and
at work I did something really cool it's
this project called broken night which
is a film a live-action film which
showed in the Tribeca Film Festival last
year starring Emily Mortimer and the
idea here is that you're inside this
film you can control it so the plot for
this without too many spoilers is that
there is this couple and they had an
argument and they they're coming back
home and then there's an intruder in the
house and you get to live that moment so
you have like for example the two
characters the man in the woman and she
takes the gun and then as a viewer you
see the pass and wherever you look
that's where the story is going to take
place so does the guy get the guns as
the girl get the gun you get to choose
and then you actually sync this
interactive video this story that you
would prefer to see so the story is not
linear it's completely interactive cool
right this leads us to our next thing
which is web augmented reality or as I
like to call it web are and if virtual
reality is all about putting you in the
virtual space augmented reality is all
about taking the virtual space and
putting it in the real space in the real
world so this example from Disney
research allows you to take like a
tablet and point it at a kid's coloring
book and whatever the kid draws like
comes into life in 3d so recent
developments in AR allow you to actually
do that or at least potentially do that
in the browser and there was a talk
about this by race
yesterday also suggest that you check
that out so we talked about web PR and
we talked about where they are and today
there is a new buzzword that if you
combine these two technologies it is now
called web X R or web extended reality
and I know
Mozilla is pushing hard on a standard
that to progress this forward and I know
I'm joking but this is like super cool
stuff so the last last thing we're going
to talk about as the physical web or the
internet of thing is and there are a lot
of interesting stuff going on there so
one of these is no BOTS which is a
movement that aims to get JavaScript on
actual robots so for example if you have
a robot and you have node and if your
computer is in Spanish then you can
actually control the robot via
JavaScript and that's pretty cool to
Mai's or or you can do something more
you know something better you can make a
cat remote control so all you need to do
in order to get that as needed Arduino
and you need the johnny-five JavaScript
library and you also probably need a cat
that's a requirement or how about
controlling and drone from your browser
on your phone so this is done via web
Bluetooth so this example from Peter
Shaughnessy shows how he's using
javascript in his browser on his phone
to connect to a drone and just fly it so
there's no app you didn't down Lenny
have to do this just like JavaScript API
and this works today on mobile chrome
and also on Samsung internet which turns
out is a browser but super super cool
that you can do that so everything that
I just showed you is is out there in the
wild you can just
use that right now what what does the
future hold
what does what's coming up next so
according to West world an HBO sci-fi
show about AI robots that run a theme
park these AI robots are written using
react so I saw Dan dance talk yesterday
he didn't say anything about robots but
maybe that's like in the next version I
don't know
hopefully yeah fingers crossed but other
upcoming technologies web USB that
allows you to connect peripherals
directly to the browser web NFC for near
field communications from the browser or
web mini for the music people among us
and I want to end with something that
gives you a little perspective this was
the first web server ever that Tim
berners-lee used in CERN and it
literally had a sticker that says this
is the Internet
don't power it down and this was the
first website that was used but then it
showed and you know what a what a way
we've done from that day to what we can
do today with web technologies I mean
that started there and we we are you
know four hundred people who are
passionate about web technologies coming
together to meeting Iceland to talk
about this thing that we're so
passionate about how amazing is that so
I'm gonna leave you with a parting gift
something an idea that might again not
be the best but it's definitely not the
worst and that is JavaScript dance party
[Music]
okay thank you so much
right before before before you leave and
before you leave him before I really
wish this stage my way my friend under
significant other - and I have to show
that I had more fun than she than her
yeah so I'm gonna take a selfie of
myself with you and you're going to make
it appear as if you've had the time of
your life in this talk and then I am
going to win because winning is
important in marriage okay okay ready
one two three
raise your hands thank you so much
you